[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander rose and the
executive director here at the long now
foundation just want to make a couple
announcements of some other talks we
have coming up at the interval on
Tuesday the 20th we have Matthew Victor
formulary with Jeff Coons studio
building all the crazy things that Jeff
Coons had to build that talk is called
artists with lasers there are still talk
tickets available for that you should be
talking about the history of artists and
technology should be a fantastic talk
the other the next talk after that is
going to be Stewart Brand and Paul
Sappho in conversation talking about pay
Slayer thinking and some of you may
remember this pay Slayer diagram that
was in Stuart's book talking about the
human layers of time and the layers of
time and civilization and it's been 15
years since that was published and a lot
of people use it as as kind of a way of
thinking about the world and design and
all kinds of things and so we're going
to be having a conversation on that now
that tuck sold out in like two hours the
interval only holds about a hundred
people but actually I wanted to find out
how many people have used the
live-streaming that we do of these talks
okay so not that many of you it was
probably our most underused awesome
thing that we have the what we are going
to do for that interval talk we have in
live street we livestream these all the
time to our members and that interval
talk will also be live streamed and
we'll try and get pictures up of the
slides if there are slides and pictures
up of the venue so any member can tune
into that talk on January 27th at 7:30
p.m. Pacific time and I know we have a
lot of a lot of people who do watch
these talks on simulcast Oh from
Australia and
in Hawaii they seemed to be in the the
better timezone for for listening the
next thing I want to talk about is
tonight's long short as you know we
generally show a short video about long
term thinking and we usually find a
subject associated with the speaker
tonight we have an early release of an
update on the 10,000 year clock project
those of you who have been following
along with the 10,000 year clock project
that we've been working on it long now
for decades we haven't had an update to
you in quite a while and we wanted to
get more done before sending something
out one of the most monumental problems
of this monument building exercise has
been how do we build the underground
space where the 10,000 year clock is
going to go and we actually used a
raised boar system which some of you may
have seen the video that we did really
several years ago of pulling a twelve
and a half foot diameter drill bit
through five hundred feet of solid rock
that is where the clock is going to go
but the way you're going to visit it we
had designed a special staircase where
every single step was cut in a different
way three dimensionally sculpted out of
that living Rock for 300 vertical feet
and there was basically no technology no
normal mining technology or no or normal
coring technology that we could use so
we worked with this amazing studio
called Seattle solstice up in Seattle
who appropriated a diamond quarrying saw
and we built a 27,000 pound robot that
has been working for the last year
making 300 vertical feet of stairs
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation Western Europe is
one of those densely populated places in
the world and has been for a very long
time there's very few national parks
almost no large protected areas like
there are in North America or in Africa
and yet something has been going on for
the last few years now is that Europe's
is being reinfected reoccupied by wolves
and brown bears and Lynx's and so the
whole trophic cascade that goes with
getting these apex predators back on the
landscape densely blended in with the
people who are welcoming them much more
than we do in North America and this is
happening pretty much by itself is a
byproduct of people moving the cities
there's a lot of abandoned farmland
grazing land and orchards and that goes
to forests and then the animals move in
pretty quickly there's also some
intentional work that has been
reintroduction of beavers into places
like Sweden they're coming to Scotland
there's just last a couple of weeks ago
reintroduction of the Spanish ibex and
to the Pyrenees and the animals are
finding their way back and the people
are finding the way to be comfortable
living with them this is not part of one
of the standard narratives about human
relations with nature right now oh it's
not being done but one of the standard
organizations that we deal with and it's
happening somewhere not here there's so
much of that kind of thing going on some
of the bad news some of it good news
that we just don't know about her
they're not part of the narratives and
one of the reasons I really value Jessie
ossible is he
globally for what's really going on on
the ground in relations between people
and nature and that's what we he'll be
talking about tonight thank you thanks
to Stuart and to Ryan felon and the long
now foundation for this opportunity to
speak with you this evening I'll speak
about trends mostly in America but that
trends that may pretend a global
restoration of nature a rebound go
warriors this work is a collective
effort with my friends and colleagues
Alan curry Jay's Ari Marchetti Peron
Mayer who's with us this evening Paul
Wagner and Ito Wernick well let's go
into the woods to begin with a scary
side effect relating to what Stuart just
mentioned a scary side effect of the
American trend to expand nature
Illustrated only about 45 miles
northwest of New York City in New Jersey
this past September a bear killed Darsh
Patel aged 22 a senior at Rutgers
University Rutgers College majoring in
information technology while he was
hiking with friends
patel's death and the app Shaw preserved
was the first fatal bear attack in New
Jersey in 150 years five friends were
actually hiking together when they came
across the bear they reacted first by
photographing and filming it here you
see a still before running in different
directions and after they regrouped they
noticed that one of their number was
missing state authorities found and
euthanized the bear which had human
remains in its stomach and esophagus and
human blood and tissue under its claws
now five years earlier the state of New
Jersey had restored its bear hunt and in
fact in 2010 wildlife biologists had
estimated that
we hunt 3400 bears living in New Jersey
and after five years of hunting the
experts now estimate that the population
is about 2,500 still and during the
six-day hunting season just a few months
ago in 2014 and six days hunters killed
267 black bears in the state of New
Jersey protesters have picketed and
petitioned to stop the annual hunt well
should the rewilding of New Jersey shock
us and I answer no because in fact about
1970 a great reversal began in America's
use of resources and contrary to the
expectation of many professors and
preachers America began to spare more
resources for the rest of nature first
in relative and more recently in
absolute terms a series of D couplings
is occurring so that our economy no
longer advances in tandem with
exploitation of land forests water and
minerals American use of almost
everything except information seems to
be peaking not because the resources are
exhausted but because consumers changed
consumption and producers changed
production changes in behavior and
technology liberate the environment well
first consider land agriculture has
always been the greatest raper of nature
stripping and simplifying and regimented
it and reducing acreage left then in
about 1940 acreage and yield decoupled
as this figure dramatically shows and
since about 1940 American farmers have
quintupled corn while using the same or
even less land now corn matters because
it sours over other crops as you see
here that total tons of corn are more
than wheat soy rice and potatoes all
together now it's crucial to note that
the
rising yields have not required more
tons of fertilizer or other inputs this
figure shows the plateau and then fall
of agricultural inputs not just crop
land but nitrogen phosphate spa - and
even water - which I will return in the
talk a recent meta-analysis by a pair of
German researchers of a hundred forty
seven original studies of recent trends
in high-yield farming for soy corn and
cotton funded by the German government
and the European Union found a 37
percent decline in chemical pesticide
use while crops rose 22% the story is
precision agriculture in which we use
more bits and not more kilowatts or
gallons importantly the average yield of
the excuse me the average yield of
American farmers or world farmers is
nowhere near a ceiling in 2013 David
hula a farmer in the Virginia Tidewater
not in Iowa or Illinois grew a world
record 454 bushels per acre which is
more than 3 times the average Iowa
grower and you can see here that his cab
looks like the office of a high speed
trader this year in 2014 his yield rose
another 5% to 476 bushels
while Randy dowdy who farms near
Valdosta Georgia not a place you think
of for corn in fact busted the 500
bushel wall for the first time of the
yield of 500 3 bushels per acre and won
the National Corn Growers contest so the
ceiling is up here and rising and the
averages are here there's a huge amount
of headroom for people still to lift
yields in America or in the world the
world average corn yields are about half
of the average American which are a
third or a quarter of what the top top
farmers are doing now of course one can
ask if Americans need all that corn we
eat only a small fraction as corn on the
cob
or cream corn or as tortillas or polenta
more most corn in fact becomes beef or
pork as you see in the green here on
this slide and increasingly we feed it
to cars as you see in the the red and in
fact an area the size of all of Iowa or
all of Alabama grows corn only two fuel
vehicles well unlike corn that becomes
beef or soybeans soybeans become chicken
potatoes stay potatoes I'm a potato guy
I really like potatoes and potatoes are
important also because they can if you
conserve potatoes then you conserve the
scarce input of water in places like
Idaho or California's Kern County around
Bakersfield but ponder what's happened
to corn growers and the the rewards of
success of the potato grower here you
see in red that the corn growers again
have lifted yields but their markets are
saturated even for french fries and
potato chips so what they've done is
remove land from production in green and
of course this land and water sparing
also is a gift for other plants and
animals
well steadily also the conversion of
crops mostly corn to meat has also
decoupled because the meat game is also
one in which efficiency matters now from
humanity's point of view cattle pigs and
chickens are just machines to make meat
and if you think of them as sort of like
model cars a steer gets about twelve
miles to the gallon while a pig gets
about forty and a chicken gets about
sixty and if you look at the statistics
for America and the world they show that
poultry which are lands efficient meat
machines they're the smart car they're
winning you can if you want to make a
pound of meat it's much better to take
some soybeans
and a chicken or a turkey than it is to
take a cow and so all over the world and
in the same way that that mp3's beat CDs
which beat tapes which beat records
chicken
as meat machine is is winning and
they're basically you know you're going
to a Toyota Prius from from a Cadillac
and the farmers the farmers understand
this there might be lots of other
rationalizations having to do with from
physicians and so forth but don't
believe it well of course the point is
that high grain and cereal yields and
efficient meat machines combined to
spare land for nature in fact we've
argued that both the US and the world
are at peak farmland not because of
exhaustion of arable land but because
farmers are wildly successful in
producing protein and calories to
prosper farmers have forced Americans to
eat hamburgers and chicken tenders to
drink bourbon and to drive with ethanol
and they have still exported massive
tonnage 'as abroad now it's important to
note that wasted food is not decoupled
from acreage and when we consider the
horrid horror of food waste either left
in the fields or at the table and not to
mention obesity then we further
appreciate that huge amounts of land can
be released from agriculture with no
damage to human diet in fact every year
1.3 billion tons of food are thrown away
globally according to UN statistics and
that equates to about one third of the
world's food being wasted now
some waste food is because of
carelessness but laws and rules
regulating food distribution also cause
it Germany the UK and other countries
are changing rules to reduce food waste
and here in California there are
websites like food cowboy which uses
mobile technology to route soup surplus
food from wholesalers and restaurants to
food banks and soup kitchens instead of
to landfills and there's also crop
mobster which tries to spread news about
local food excess and surplus from
suppliers the 800 million or so hungry
humans are not hungry because of
inadequate production well if we keep
lifting average yields
that to the demonstrated levels of David
hula and Randy dowdy if we stopped
feeding core into cars if we restrain
our diets lightly and if we reduce waste
then according to calculations that
we've published in recent years an area
the size of India or the u.s. east of
the Mississippi or even more could be
released globally from agriculture over
the next 50 years or so there's plenty
of calories and protein out there
probably much much more than we need to
grow and in fact rebound is already
happening abandonment of marginal
agricultural lands in the former Soviet
Union in Eastern Europe has released at
least 30 million and perhaps as much as
60 million hectares to return to nature
30 million hectares is the size of
Poland or Italy Stewart mentioned this
the great reversal of land use that I'm
describing is not something hypothetical
it's not it's a forecast it's a present
reality in Russia and Poland as well as
Pennsylvania and Michigan and at the end
of the talk I'll show some of the
consequences I talked about corn as I
said the total amount of corn fed to
cars in America is equal to Iowa or
Alabama think of organizations like long
now turning all those lands that are now
pasture for cars into refuges for
wildlife Carbon orchards and parks the
area is about twice the area of all the
national parks in the States outside
Alaska
well let's now turn from farms to
forests foresters refer to a forest
transition when a nation goes from
losing to gaining forested area and
France recorded the first transition the
first forest transition about the Year
1830 and since that time French forests
have doubled while French population has
also doubled as you see here so forest
area decoupled from population in France
now measured by growing stock the u.s.
enjoyed its forest transition around
1950 as you see
the right and measured by area about
1990 as you see
excuse me out the growing stock on the
left and the Timberland area on the
right
forests can spread they can also become
more dense it's like a city a city can
you can have taller buildings and more
MORE higher density in a city or you can
spread so far estate in the area in the
event the density are increasing in the
US and in about 60 other temperate
countries in fact in the u.s. the forest
transition began around 1900 when states
such as Connecticut in in black year
1907 or earlier and Pennsylvania New
York started the transition and you can
see it spreads so that now in fact
forests appear to be increasing in at
least all the lower 48 states California
joined in 1997 from the forests decrease
to forest increase now in fact the thick
green cover where I come from in New
York or Pennsylvania or all of New
England would would have been
unrecognizable to to Teddy Roosevelt one
of the most famous conservationists he
knew he knew the parts of the country
that where I live and work as wheat
fields pastures moan by sheep and Hills
denuded by logging now it's important to
understand that the forest transition
like pink peak farmland involves forces
of both supply and demand
foresters manage the supply better
through smarter harvesting and
replanting simply shifting harvesting
from cool slow growing forests to warmer
faster growing ones can make a
difference
growth in cool and warm US forests
differed recently by about a factor of
two about 3.6 cubic meters in the cool
area 7.4 and the warmer ones and in fact
the shift of the US forest industry to
the southeast between 1976 and 2001 from
the cool regions to the warmer ones
actually had caused a net decrease of
logged area in the US of about 3 million
hectares which is far more than the
point nine million hectares of
Yellowstone Park
or the 1.3 million hectares of
Connecticut now like farmed meat forest
plantations also produce wood more
efficiently than unmanaged forests and
forest plantations meet a growing
fraction of demand all over the world
whether in New Zealand Brazil US and
they also meet that demand predictably
and they can spare other forests for
biodiversity and other benefits and the
growth in plantations versus natural
forests provides an even greater
contrast than just the cool and the warm
Brazilian eucalyptus plant plantations
provide about 40 cubic meters per
hectare per year about five times a warm
natural forest in almost ten times a
cool northern forest in recent times
about a third of wood production comes
from plantations and if that were to
increase to 75% then the logged area of
natural forests could drop in half
globally now it's easy to appreciate
it's a very simple logic if plantations
merely grow twice as fast as natural
forests harvesting one hectare of
plantation spares two hectares of
natural forest an equally important
story unfolds on the demand side we once
used wood to heat our homes and for
almost forgotten uses such as railroad
ties the Iron Horse the Train was
actually a wooden horse with rails
resting on countless trees that made the
ties and trestles and the trains
themselves were wooden carriages the the
President as president of the Southern
Pacific and Central Pacific Railroad's
in their largest expansion one of your
local heroes Leland Stanford was
probably one of the greatest deforesters
in world history it's not surprising
that he publicly advocated for
conservation of forests because he knew
how railroads cut them the u.s. Forest
Service originated around 1900 in large
part to an expected timber famine caused
by expansion of railroads
fortunately for nature the length of the
railroad system saturated creosote
preserve timber longer and concrete
replaced it this chart shows the three
major uses of wood fuel construction and
paper and it shows how wood for fuel and
building has lost importance since 1960
and world production also has saturated
here you see saw logs and veneer and red
round wood in construction in blue wood
fuel in green and paper and paperboard
in yellow and you can see that the the
demand since about 1990 for the round
wood the the saw logs and the wood fuel
has been flat it's not a good time to
own shares these companies there was a
market for for pulp and paper for a
while growing until the early 2000s it
had been the bright spot but after
decades of wrong forecasts of the
paperless society we must now credit
West Coast tycoons Steve Jobs and Jeff
Bezos for Erie ders and tablets which
have caused the market for pulp and
paper the last strong sector of wood
products to crumple where are the new
stands and stationers of yesteryear many
paper products such as steno pads and
even fan fold computer paper are
artifacts for the technology museum's
email has collapsed mail as this figure
shows as a Rockefeller University
employee I like to point out that john d
rockefeller saved the whales by
replacing sperm oil with petroleum well
ARPANET merits a medal for forest
rebound well so far I've described
bottom-up and forces relating to farms
and forests that spare land but top-down
forces are also at work and together the
forces are causing global greening
global greening the most important
ecological trend on earth or at least on
land today the biosphere on land is
getting bigger year by year
about two billion tonnes or even more
and researchers are reporting the
evidence weekly here are abstracts from
half a dozen papers published in the
last year so on the upper left shifts
and Arctic vegetation and associated
feedbacks under climate change massive
greening in the Arctic over the next few
decades below that a paper just
published last last week 2015 ground and
satellite based evidence of the
biophysical mechanisms behind the
greening Sahel sub-saharan Africa
various remote sensing studies observed
a positive trend and vegetative
greenness known as the regaining of the
Sahel below that forest and growth
dynamics and central Europe's have
educated have accelerated since 1870 on
the right side northern ecosystems than
the story about Russia and Belarus that
I've already mentioned below on the
right impact of co2 fertilization on
maximum foliage cover across the globe's
warm arid environments places like
Australia now probably the most obvious
reason is simply the increase of the
greenhouse gas carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere and of course farmers pumped
co2 into greenhouses to to make plants
grow better co2 is what many plants
inhale to feel good and it also enables
plants to grow more while using the same
or less water so there's the co2 itself
and Californians famous Californians
David Keeling and his son Ralph Keeling
at Scripps Institution of Oceanography
have kept superfine measurements of co2
since 1958 and here you can see the
increasing size of the what's called the
seasonal cycle of co2 on the top the
year the average for the years 1958 to
61 in in black and the larger
oscillation in purple of the average of
2009 11 and the same data charted in a
different way below and you can see that
in the in the recent period there's a
bigger amplitude of the fluctuation
between the the summer when the the
plants absorb inhale that carbon dioxide
and the fall in winter when it gets
released and the fact that this bigger
breathing is going on is reflects the
the increase
size of the biosphere especially in the
in the Northern Hemisphere as reported
now in a whole series of papers but this
increase it's a global phenomenon and
potentially enlarging the biosphere you
know in almost all regions now also in
some areas especially the high latitudes
of the Northern Hemisphere the growing
the growing season has lengthened
attributed to global warming and
whatever we may think about it the
longer growing season is also causing
more plant growth demonstrated the most
impressively convincingly in Finland
some papers have come out there with
very detailed province by province study
of Finland looking at detailed climate
records the longer growing season and
showing more growth in Finland and I
mentioned sub-saharan Africa which may
be connected with more rain now there's
also more nitrogen around in the
biosphere these days and the more
nitrogen here and there in the
environment may also be contributing to
the the global greening a group of us is
now trying to dissect or attribute let's
say the two billion tonnes or whatever
the right number is to longer growing
seasons to abandonment of agriculture to
nitrogen and so forth it's going to take
some some careful work over over the
coming couple of years but in any case
the numbers are huge and the effect is
global and in this this slide shows a
satellite comparison of the biosphere in
1982 and in 2011 and you can see 31
percent of the global vegetated area
greened 14 percent increase in gross
productivity and it's seen in all
vegetation types and in the Amazon and
West Africa and Central Africa and in
India and China just everywhere I would
repeat that global greening is the most
important ecological phenomenon on land
today well in speaking about land I've
occasionally mentioned materials such as
nitrogen and water and let me now
suggest that in addition to peak
farmland and peak timber America may
also be experiencing peak use of many
other resources back in the 1970s we
thought America's growing appetite
I might exhaust Earth's crust of just
about every metal and mineral but a
surprising thing happened even as our
population kept growing the intensity of
use of the resources began to fall first
that is the amount we use per dollar so
to say for each new dollar we didn't use
the same copper or steel that we had and
here you can see the change in not just
the relative but the absolute use of
nineteen of nine basic commodities from
2009 to 2010 and it's easy to understand
why in 1970 I was out there advocating
for Earth Day
if you were in 1970 looking back you saw
everything going up and if you were in
the film The Graduate you predicted that
plastics would grow the most and that's
the red line growing at the top but you
see that between nineteen ninety seventy
and nineteen ninety things began to
flatten and then about and actually peak
and so now you see plastics paper timber
phosphate potash LED aluminum steel
copper in absolute use in the United
States all of them falling well this
reversal of use surprised me and my
colleagues so much that we started a
detailed study of a hundred commodities
in the u.s. from 1900 to 2010 and 100
commodities span just about everything
you can think of in the material world
from arsenic and asbestos to water and
zinc and of the hundred we found that
only thirty that excuse me that
thirty-six already have peaked in
absolute use here are eight shown
chromium fluorspar pig iron iron or some
nasty ones like cadmium and asbestos
good riddance to most of them so you can
you see things rising up to nineteen
seventy or so then plateauing then
falling and actually dropping way down
in the use of some of them so 36 of the
hundred are already falling we found
another 53 that
appear to be plateauing and probably
think are likely to fall many of them if
not all of the 53 here you see again a
subset of of eight electricity at the
top which may also be plateauing then
nickel nitrogen cement petroleum which
I'll return later cobalt cropland and
water but which I'll say more about so
these appear near peak we found only 11
commodities that are still growing in
both relative and absolute use and this
shows eight of them and explains the
title of our forthcoming report which is
chickens and gallium and chickens of
course are winning the meat war and most
of the other elements that are growing
are vitamins like the gallium and indium
used to dope or alloy other bulk
materials and make them smarter or
niobium the helium for birthday parties
has other uses but but really one in a
sense one again one can think that you
know it's it's more information because
what rhenium or gallium or indium does
is it takes something it's a vitamin it
takes something that's a bit dumb as a
material and makes it much smarter by
adding good properties so what's the
result of this well it's
dematerialization and dematerialization
is no surprise of course to San
Franciscans because you've caused it
you've made the devices that replace the
big old clumsy hunks of metal and blobs
of plastic pictured on the right of the
figure so enormous numbers of devices
that used to use lots of materials are
largely becoming obsolete and replaced
by by by more compact systems well an
astonishing thing is that water you know
and I think even California is
economizing on water during this drought
of the last three or four years maybe
surprised to see what's happened to
water withdrawals in America since
nineteen seventy this figure first shows
in the straight lines that the expert
projections made in the 1970s of water
use what water used to
the year 2000 would be and the magenta
segments show what actually happened so
instead of rising water use was flat
while America added eighty million
people we added the population of Turkey
to the United States and water you
stayed flat and in fact as this slide
mentions and as this slide shows what
water used through 2010 which is the
latest set of data has actually now
declined to levels below 1970 this is
data just released by the US Geological
Survey and as the figure notes
production of corn has tripled while
this has gone on and the largest reasons
are more efficient water use in farming
and also more efficient use in power
generation well in the land of lyft and
uber I must speak about petroleum and
mobility too and this figure shows
per-capita petroleum use rising into a
1970 Plymouth Roadrunner I hope at least
one person here had one and most experts
worried about further Rises but this is
what actually happened to perk a per
capita apparent consumption in the US a
plateau and then fall and partly
vehicles have become more efficient but
also partly travel and personal vehicles
seems to have saturated this is a figure
that's a little harder to read it's from
the federal highway administration but
in blue you see annual vehicle distance
traveled for personal vehicles and
billions of miles and you can see that
for about ten years it's been flat so
even before the drought little drop
comes in 2008 with the Great Recession
one can ask whether we're at peak
vehicle miles and personal vehicle
personal vehicles the the Green Line
shows the year-to-year year on your
change in vehicle miles traveled and on
the left and 1971 at the start it was
growing by 6% and on the right it's
fluctuating around
zero well so we may be at peak our
travel now if you buy an extra car it's
probably for fashion or flexibility you
won't spend more minutes per day driving
or drive more miles and unlike the car
companies I would not bet on selling a
lot more cars either this figure fits a
curve smoothly to the population of cars
in the USA and we seem to be near peak
car and some comparable studies in the
UK suggest the same thing there
now the reason of course may be that
drone taxis are winning the average
personal vehicle motors about an hour
per day but a shared car like a zip car
is used let's say eight hours a day and
a taxi even more as venture capitalists
here know driverless cars can work
tirelessly and safely and accomplish the
present mileage with many fewer vehicles
the manufacturers won't like it
but markets do simply fade away as for
typewriters and newsprint and moreover
new forms of transport can enter the
game according to our studies the best
bet is on magnetically levitated systems
or maglevs trains with magnetic
suspension and propulsion Elon Musk has
proposed a variant calls the Hyperloop
that would speed between Los Angeles and
San Francisco at about a thousand
kilometers an hour 600 miles an hour
accomplishing the trip in about 35
minutes and thus comfortably allowing
daily round trips very important if the
local arrangements are also quick now
the maglev is a vehicle without wings
wheels and motor and thus without
combustibles aboard safe and its
suspended magnetically between two
guardrails which resemble an open state
or of an electric motor and it can be
either pushed propelled by a magnetic
field or pulled that run by a field that
runs in front and the hard limits to the
possible speed of maglevs don't really
exist in a sense they're more like
aircraft and if they run in evacuated
tunnels as a number of us have advocated
for some years and has MA
musk has also proposed they can go very
very fast evacuated means simulating
let's say the atmosphere at 30,000 feet
the low pressure that an airplane
encounters and these can be in tunnels
that would solve the problem of
landscape disturbance or they could be
in tubes mounted above existing
rights-of-way of roads or rails which
might prove easier and cheaper to build
it's important to note that they're
spared a motor and they're also spared
the belly fat called fuel you know a
goose and an airplane are really the
same thing you have you have you have
kerosene in the belly of the aircraft
and you have goose fat in the belly of
the goose they fly and after they've
flown across the Atlantic they've burned
up their fuel well belly fat is its
weight and the Maglev could break
something we call the rule of the ton
though which has burden mobility the
weight of a horse and its gear a train
per passenger and an auto which on
average carries a little more than one
passenger or a jumbo jet at takeoff with
all its fuel all averaged about one ton
of vehicle per passenger but a maglev
could slim to let's say 300 kilos a
third or less and of course if you have
much lighter vehicles than immediately
you drop drastically the cost of energy
transport so the maglevs could solve
this problem that transport engineers
have not been able to solve now you can
ask will maglevs make a sprawl and it's
a legitimate fear cars did it but in
contrast to the car you can think of
maglevs is offering the alternative of a
bimodal or virtual city with pedestrian
islands and fast connections between
them bag labs could function as national
and continental scale metros at jet
speed and this being San Francisco I'll
look farther into the and the long now
look farther into the 21st century and
we can imagine a system that's really a
maglev system that would really be quite
wondrous the you know sort of you know
in the same way that the maker of the
Stutz Bearcat probably couldn't have
imagined the freeway system but but
think of the maglev
system as a set of magnetic bubbles
moving under the control of a central
computer and what we put inside the
bubbles is immaterial it could be a
personal or small collective vehicle
starting for example as an elevator in a
skyscraper coming down becoming a taxi
in the Maglev network and then again
becoming an elevator in another
skyscraper so you can have this entire
sort of bizarre of maglev bubbles run
like a videogame we're shuffling Andry
routing would lead the vehicle to its
destination swiftly following the model
of the Internet in the end the maglev
system is a common carrier or highway
meaning private as well as mass vehicles
can shoot through it so over the course
of century the century that can be built
and among other things this would mean
that the city air will be even cleaner
if the source of electricity is clean
maglev Tsar it's an electrical system
and but in fact Americans have been
doing a pretty good job of also of
decoupling growth and air quality and we
can see that it's not just decoupling
but in fact we've experienced absolute
Falls in pollution here you see
emissions of sulfur dioxide a classic
air pollutant which peaked about 1970
because of a blend of factors including
better technology and stronger
regulation the and the arc of this
sulfur dioxide forms a classic curve in
which pollution first grows as people
get a bit richer and then Falls as
Americans grew richer still and
preferred clean air the that's one of
the real successes what about carbon
dioxide I think we also have probably
experienced peak carbon dioxide
emissions in the US this figure the the
chart the data only goes through 2007
that was the peak year of emissions from
energy for the US and now since 2007 in
the emissions were about 10% below 2007
to 2014 data aren't out yet we may you
know now with the
falling oil prices things may plateau
for a while again but I think the basic
idea the basic idea is is clear that
we're we're and it's you know it's a
it's a story repeated in many ways and I
would say these trajectories for for the
sulphur dioxide or for the carbon
emissions is important to me I think
they're preset not created by public
policy or politicians as the German
politician Bismarck said in a speech in
1895 a statesman does not create the
stream he floats on it and tries to
steer in California terms the best
politicians are surfers winning
attention for wide riding waves the now
I've spoken about farms forests
materials including water and mobility
and let me report very briefly on human
population as well the u.s. fertility
rate declined six years in a row being
beginning in 2008 it's now at one point
eight six below the the per woman below
the the famous replacement level of two
point one now immigration will keep will
continue to keep the US population
growing but globally it appears that
earth is passing peak child Swedish
statistician and physician Hans rustling
who many of you know for may know from
his famous Gapminder talk on TED talk
estimates that the absolute number of
humans born reached about a hundred
thirty million in 1990 and has stayed
around that number since then and with
declining fertility all over the world
which you see here including the world
in the purple down to the replacement
level of 2.1 the number of newcomers
should soon fall now while momentum
younger people and greater longevity of
the people who are here people born
today are expected to live in the US are
expected to live between 108 and 112 so
the long now matters or the children or
the the young children of people in this
room will be a lot could well be alive
in the year 2120 but with
with the slow growth in population or no
growth technical progress can counter
the likely mouths it's very simple if
you have a 2% per year gain and
efficiency which is something engineers
can certainly do that can dominate a
growth of population of 1% or even less
well if only everything we're trending
in the right direction
some of my oceans colleagues are here
and I explore and observe the oceans a
lot and ocean life is getting a raw deal
still let's think a little bit about the
form of meat called fish consider the
change in the catch of a charter boat
out of Key West between 1958 and 2007
you can see there were no more large
groupers in 2007 in the same charter
boat or take a trip to the Tokyo fish
market sea life is astonishingly
astonishingly delicious and tastier and
more varied in markets than ever
owing to improved storage and transport
so an octopus from Mauritania as in this
photo ends in Japan now before the
advent of refrigeration fresh sushi was
a delicacy for the Emperor of Japan in
2001 a 489 pound bluefin sold for one
point seven six million dollars in Tokyo
and we may say that the democratization
of sushi has changed everything for sea
life here are a few slides of the from
2000 this was 2011 auction in in Tokyo
you see the bluefin here I mentioned the
peak at the auction carried away
butchered red meat
well the you can just see that the the
story for marine life let's say it's a
hundred years behind the land fish
biomass and intensively exploited
fisheries appears to be about one-tenth
the level of the fish in those areas a
few decades or a hundred years ago for
example the total estimated kilos of cod
off Cape Cod today probably weigh in
fact only about three percent of the
call the cod in 1815 the average
swordfish harpooned off new england
dropped in size from about five hundred
pounds in 1860 to about two hundred
pounds already in 1930 and of course
most of the swordfish sold now in new
england come from the south atlantic to
survive wild in the ocean and
unprotected species needs to enjoy
juvenile sex and spawn before capture
you have to live fast and die young well
earlier we spoke about land meat and how
does world consumption of fish that
depletes the ocean compared to the eight
hundred million tonnes or so of animal
products that humanity eats fish meat is
about one-fifth of land meat in 2012
about 90 million tons of fish were taken
wild from salt and freshwater about 80
million from salt and about 10 million
from fresh and a fast-growing 66 million
tons from fish farms and ranches now
americans in fact eat little sea life
about seven kilos per person per year
but much of that is from the wild
schools of the sea and even though
that's small globally it depletes the
oceans because there are 320 million of
us but the ancient sparing of land
animals by farming shows us how to spare
the fish in the sea if we want to eat
sea life we need to raise the share we
farm and lower the share we catch fish
farming doesn't require invention it's
been around for a long time the chinese
have been doing it very nicely raising
herbivores such as carp for centuries
and following the chinese example one
feeds crops grown on land by farmers too
or beaver as fish and ponds and much at
much aquaculture of catfish
near the Gulf of Mexico or of carp until
Apia in Southeast Asia and the
Philippines takes this form the fish
grown in the ponds spare fish from the
ocean and like poultry fish convert
protein in feed to protein and meat and
because the fish do not have to stand up
at all the water supports them they
convert calories to feed into meat even
more efficiently than poultry let's say
80 miles per gallon rather than 60 or 40
well all the improvements such as
breeding and Disease Control that have
made poultry production more efficient
can can be and have been applied to
aquaculture improving the conversion of
feed to meat and sparing wild fish now
in some fish ranching I'll call it
notably most of today's ranching of
salmon the salmon effectively grazed the
oceans as the Razorback hogs of a
primitive farmer grazed the oak woods
such aquaculture consists of catching
small wild fish such as men hayden
anchovies and sardines or their oil and
feeding them to our herd such as the
salmon in pens we changed the form of
the fish from from menhaden
to salmon but we had economic value but
we don't change the stocks in fact we
may reduce them well we need a shift
from ocean ranching to true farming that
will spare the depletion and that's one
way to do it or we can try to persuade
salmon and other carnivores to eat tofu
and in fact this should happen very soon
cobia sometimes called kingfish
widespread in the Caribbean and other
warm waters grows up to two metres big
fish 80 kilos and they their favor diet
is crab squid and smaller fish well
recently Aaron Watson and other
researchers at the University of
Maryland have turned this carnivore into
a vegetarian
they have a mixture of plant-based
proteins fatty acids and an amino acid
substance very much like the one in
energy energy drinks that your children
favor and it pleases the cobia as well
as bream and conversion of these
carnivorous
fished a completely vegetarian diet
breaks the cycle in which fish fish
ranchers plunder the oceans small fish
to provide the feed for the big fish and
you can see in the top right of this
chart in the the dark blue this is a
chart from the Food and Agriculture
Organization of the FAO that all the
growth of of fish meat since about 1985
1990 has been through aquaculture the we
are at peak fish not for good reasons
from the capture production so if we
want more we need to we need to go to
aquaculture and at camp it's not just
fish we can do the same for the filter
feeders the oysters clams and mussels we
have to take care for effluence
pathogens and other concerns now
eventually we might grow fish not in the
oceans at all but in closed silos at
high density feeding them proteins made
by microorganisms grown on hydrogen
nitrogen and carbon and the fish could
be sturgeon filled with caviar and in
fact much of the caviar now sold in
Moscow is raised in fish farms in the Po
Valley in northern Italy there's not
much wild sturgeon left in the Volga
well the point is that the high levels
of harvest of wild fishes and
destruction of marine habitats to
capture them need not continue and the
40% of seafood in the dark blue and the
chart already raised by aquaculture
signals the potential for reversal with
smart aquaculture life in the oceans can
rebound while feeding humanity and
restoring nature now because California
at least Northern California is the
world capital of experimentation in
cuisine let me offer an alternative more
radical idea than vegetarian salmon we
can understand that in a world of 7
billion human mouths aquaculture must
largely replace hunting of the wild
animals for many maybe all forms of
marine life and were accustomed to the
reality that even vast America does not
produce enough wild ducks or wild
blueberries to satisfy our habit
but back to basics we depend on the
hydrogen produced by the chlorophyll of
plants and as my colleague Marchetti has
pointed out once you have hydrogen
produced for example by means of nuclear
energy a plethora of microorganisms are
capable of cooking it into the variety
of substances in our kitchens and
researchers in the space programs in
fact for decades have been producing
food conceived for astronauts on the way
to Mars by cultic cultivating hydrogen
ammonia x' on a diet of hydrogen carbon
dioxide and a little oxygen and they
make proteins that taste a little bit
like hazelnut now a person concerned
consumes about a hundred watts the
Diablo Canyon nuclear power park
operates to eleven hundred megawatt
electric power plants on about nine
hundred acres or 1.5 square miles and
the power of Diablo Canyon a couple of
gigawatts therefore could supply food
for a few million people more than 2,000
per acre more than ten times what David
hula or Randy Doughty achieved with corn
you could imagine a single spherical
fermenter of about a hundred yards in
diameter producing the primary food for
the 30 million inhabitants of Mexico
City the foods would of course be
formatted before arriving at the
consumer you may be grimacing but
observe that our most sophisticated
foods like cheese's and wines are the
product of sophisticated
elaboration by microorganisms of simple
feedstocks such as milk and grape juice
so the the microorganisms as chefs
shouldn't be underestimated
well globally the food system like this
could allow humanity to release 90% of
the land and sea
now exploited for food now in Petaluma
and Eureka humanity might maintain
artisanal farming and fishing to provide
supreme flavorings for the bulk tofu
well I don't expect ninety percent to be
shared so be space
but I do think Humanity is moving toward
landless agriculture or progressively
using less land for food and that we
should aim to release for nature an area
the size of India by 2050 overall I
think the next decades present an
enormous opportunity for what Stuart and
Ryan call revive and restore people will
object that I've spoken little about
China and India and Africa but I respond
with a remark of Gertrude Stein who came
from nearby Auckland Stein said about
1930 that America is the oldest country
in the world because America has been in
the 20th century longer than and than
any other country in fact as early as
1873 America became the world's largest
economy and since then a
disproportionate share of the products
and habits that diffused throughout the
world have come from America
particularly California my view is that
the patterns described are not
exceptional to the US and that within a
few decades the same patterns in fact
already evident in Europe and Japan will
be evident in many more places now
rebound is not without challenges we
considered the black bear and the
college student to begin later in the
long now seminar series you'll discuss
the challenges of a woolly mammoth but
consider the Fox Fox experts now that
estimate that about 10,000 foxes roam
the City of London more than the
double-decker buses as you can see foxes
ride the London Underground for free the
Mayor of London Boris Johnson became
enraged when his cat appeared to be
mauled by a fox which was accused of
being a fair beater as well and English
snipers in fact charge $120 to shoot a
fox in your in your city garden but and
meanwhile in rural England Badgers are
causing an uncivil war between farmers
and animal protection groups and you
know more about Bob
in California than I so we have a new
round of what journalist Jim sturby has
chronicled in a great book called nature
wars the incredible story of how
wildlife come backs turned backyards
into battle grounds but I want to end
not with complications but with
inspiration with examples of why we want
rebound rewilding why we want a
rapprochement with nature why the
achievement of farmers David hula and
Randy dowdy and aquaculture Astaire and
Watson and their counterparts in
forestry and water and materials matter
the incipient rewilding of Europe that
Stuart mentioned is thrilling salmon
have returned to the Rhine and to the
CIN links have returned to several
countries wolves have returned to Italy
reindeer herds have rebounded in
Scandinavia I mentioned Eastern Europe a
couple of times
enjoy these photographs of bison that
have returned to Poland these and the
preceding photos come from a new film
about rewilding the seasons from the
French filmmaker and producer Jacques
Perrin
who made the film's wing at migration
about long-distance migration of birds
and micro cosmos about insects the
seasons are scheduled for release in
December 2016
my final still image which was on the
first slide as well comes not from
Europe but from the entrance to New York
Harbor I proposed this image of a
humpback whale with the Empire State
Building in the background is the most
significant in my environmental American
environmental image of 2014 humpback
whales and other cetaceans perhaps even
blue whales are returning in large
numbers to New York Bight recall the
whale despair of the 1970s and
considered that the Bronx Zoo has just
announced a program together with the
Woods Hole Oceanographic Institution to
monitor whale numbers and movements in
sight of New York City many decades
without hunting and improved Hudson
River
water quality have made a difference
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
so they have a seat Jesse yeah you
remind me more buckminster fuller than
anybody I've met in a long time he used
to talk about ephemeral ization doing
more of it less and you've got the
materialization and you throw all those
numbers out there and people get excited
nobody else makes people excited about
number Sifl you know you've had a
leadership role in the census of marine
life report a little bit on what came
out of that yes
in the late 1990s group of people
interested in marine life all around the
world decided that for the first time we
should have a census we should try to
provide information on diversity
distribution and abundance how many
forms of life there are in the ocean
where they live their addresses their
ranges and abundance how many kilos or
pounds of the different forms and from
2000 to 2010 we in fact were able to
conduct the census there were 540
expeditions about 3,000 people
participated from 80 countries and the
good news is we discovered 6,000 new
species we made new estimates of the
total forms of life in the ocean we made
the first comprehensive list of all the
known forms we estimated that there are
a million or more forms of life still to
be discovered in the ocean so they're
still naming opportunities we discovered
all kinds of blue highways where the
animals travel and lots of new
information about ranges so I'd say with
regard to diversity and distribution
there was a lot of one might say good
news on the abundance side as you saw
with the slide of the the recreational
charter boat in Key West we found very
disturbing news basically most of the
species that have entered human commerce
have plummeted in quantity not
extinct extinction is very unusual in
the oceans because they're so large
they're usually a few left but huge
drops in population and they're of
course great questions now about whether
the total biomass in the ocean has
changed you know have jellies or or
squids or others grown in number to
compensate for the the losses of the cod
and the others so but at least there is
a baseline for the first time and we
hope in 2020 or 2025 the world may
conduct a second census and begin to put
in place a global ocean observing system
that can go from the snapshot to a video
or a movie and report in a timely way to
us the changes good and bad that are
occurring so one of the things that the
environmental movement really focused on
in the 1970s was saving the whales and
the policy changed and and not just
through the Standard Oil but through you
know stopping the hunting the oils
except for a few skilled by Japan which
you know this is a big slowly
reproducing mammals I want to take them
to get back or are they already back to
what they were before some populations
of whales have regrown well here on the
west coast there have been some very
encouraging estimates even about the
blue whales that the number of blue
whales I think is now back up also to
about 3,000 estimated all up and down
the coast from numbers and you know
perhaps 300 or 400 so I you know with
with the animals that wait you know wait
till they're teenagers to to have sex
you know you have you have to be very
patient with animals like squid that can
grow very fast and and have very short
life cycles the recovery can be much
much quicker but some of us have talked
about the idea of having a just a global
moratorium on disturbing sea life world
war two was the best thing that happened
in the 20th century to marine life
basically for five years there was much
much less fishing and in 1946
in the Atlantic and the Pacific there
were a lot more animals than there were
in 1939 and so we know if you leave
things alone especially the larger
animals will grow back and maybe we need
a maybe we need a decade of peace with
the oceans or a generation to allow a
very substantial regrowth and as I said
in my remarks I think we we have I think
humanity has to cut back on it so on the
capture of wild fish and the consumption
of wild fish if we want if we want fish
meat we need to move to to aquaculture
so a version of that is that presumably
these protected areas which are suddenly
multiplying rapidly is that did the fish
know to go there and reproduce the
marina there are many forms of marine
life there are many ways of making a
living in the ocean so you have
completely sessile creatures that
succeeded like a barnacle and then you
have animals like tuna that may swim
between Los Angeles and an Tokyo or
Yokohama in a few months so one has to
have strategies for the sessile species
and these highly mobile species and and
everything in between the marine
protected areas are most important for
the species that are sessile or have
small ranges it's possible for tuna
though to have areas you know the the
tunas breed at certain times of the year
in certain places like the northern Gulf
of Mexico so it's also possible to put
in transient or ephemeral protection
where you say lino for these 60 days or
90 days you should leave a particular
area alone so you know I think there are
reasonable strategies now there are
removal direct removal eating is still
the biggest problem for marine life but
of course destruction of habitat
pollution coming out of rivers you know
there are there are other other problems
as well and those need to be those need
to be addressed in their ways do you eat
fish I eat very little sea life I don't
use the term seafood and
except in a very narrow way I regard
most forms of life in my ocean in the
ocean as my friends and I don't
I've stopped enjoying eating eating sea
life for the most part there are some
exceptions but I eat very little sea
life and I don't feel that way about
chickens though
Chelsea santur asks how are biodiversity
hotspots addressed in your studies for
example Indonesian force and palm versus
you know keeping orangutangs and so on
well Indonesia is the most tragic
location on earth now for people
concerned about losses you know that any
given slike births and deaths at any
given time you know there's always going
to be a net there you know things are
growing and things are being cut in
various places and the if you if you
look at the negative side of the ledger
Indonesia even more than Brazil is the
place where the the the losses of
forests and the animals that live in the
forests and so forth is his most
heartbreaking in those areas I think one
needs a very one needs very specific
kinds of action to try to stop those
those losses now what I've described
mostly is a global a set of global
trends and that those what's happening
globally doesn't necessarily describe
what's happening in in Sausalito or in
any particular place so what always has
to be careful the global generalization
there true globally but they'll always
be places where where one needs other
strategies now hotspots in protected
areas the in the only first marine
protected area in the world was created
in La Jolla Cove in the early 1970s the
very first almost a hundred years after
the first national parks in the US and
elsewhere so as I in many ways the
oceans are a hundred years behind the
land so we have less experience on how
to protect the oceans and we've
protected much less of it I think on
land
in the various forms of protection that
exists in one place or another and have
now existed for many decades you know in
the case of yellowstone or yosemite and
so forth
the i think we the vocabulary the
toolkit is pretty good on land and i
think people have a pretty good sense of
what works now it's important to say
that as i suggested with jeff about the
e-readers Kindles and so forth solutions
sometimes come from unexpected places
you know as some of the people concerned
with with conservation of tigers and
rhinos will tell you one of the
solutions is little blue pills viagra
tiger bone and rhino horn in fact do not
cure erectile dysfunction but Viagra and
Cialis do and some people have said you
should just give away little blue pills
in chinese markets and you know take
destroy the market for the for the the
tiger bone and rhino horn and i think
those kinds of ideas need to be taken
very seriously and again the the you if
one shouldn't think of conservation or
conservationists only as the people who
you know lobby for conservation in very
traditional ways again the the these you
know if you look at forests or or food
or any of these things or materials you
know the dematerialization all this
didn't come because the environmental
groups of which you know many of them i
you know i'm i donate and so forth but
they were they none of them in the 70s
or 80s said we need a program on
dematerialization and we need to get rid
of of vacuum tube TVs and you know you
know you can look back through
everything they didn't even think about
it so so solutions can come from you
know from unexpected places and i think
we have to keep our ears and eyes open
for that one other question on seafood
tim KS why does seafood sustainability
guys encourage wild caught fish and shun
farmed food for example salmon
well they're aquaculture like any
industry like the whatever the private
carting industry or or plumbers or
electricians or jazz musicians there
there are people who are good at it and
people who are not so good at it and
it's a young industry and I think there
have been quite a few people who were
sloppy or careless one needs monitoring
and regulation so I think part of the
part of the negativity in some quarters
about aquaculture has to do with bad
practices in a young industry part of it
has to do with a romantic idea that
somehow something wild is better than
something farmed that but the problem is
in a world of 7.3 billion people and
even more and a billion people now eat
sushi
so you just the things that you know if
only you or I went out of you know went
and caught a few fish salmon from the
Klamath River or whatever it might be
okay but it just doesn't work a lot of
these so I think there's I think the
people who are promoting while eating
wild sea life on more than a very as
more than a treat for the rich are just
it's just it's just a very dangerous
idea it can't be it can't work in a
world with a lot of prosperous people
there's a question basically relating to
efficiency and concentration from John
Sanfilippo great efficiency leads to
great vulnerability monocrops
concentration we bring disease crop
failure etcetera this is a question of
political and economic concentration
versus democracy what are the what are
the vulnerabilities of this kind of
efficiency and concentration well
certainly as I showed that you know the
tower of corn you know if bad things
were happened to happen to corn it could
really be catastrophic
the I think one always needs lot
of research one needs very good
monitoring of a range of things weather
insects and so forth I don't think III
think there's an arrogance in much of
the world at least much of the developed
world place like America about farmers
people think farmers are dumb because we
don't do it anymore in fact farming is
as successful as telecommunications and
computer science and all the things that
go on out here as I tried to show the
you know the the what farmers have
accomplished one can say in ten thousand
years but just in the last 50 or 60
years is almost beyond belief in terms
of the calories and protein so I think
we have to be very careful not to think
these people are stupid or incompetent
or lazy they're very very good at what
they do in the same way that that
company's operating the
telecommunication system are at the same
time one always has to take some
attention to catastrophic failure you
know whether it's whether it's with
regard to water systems or or food
systems or electric power and so they're
they're always you know any big system
has has vulnerabilities at the same time
I think that there's a real
misunderstanding about world agriculture
the problem in world agriculture is not
shortages the problem is this incredible
success has led to this obesity too much
meat eating a third of the food being
wasted and much more land being used
than needs to be so you know people who
worry that whatever climate change will
reduce agricultural production by 18
percent in 2050 my view is we could
reduce agricultural production by 50
percent right now and actually have a
better world now that's not to say the
income of farmers should go down I'm
happy you know to to you know to pay
people to do very to produce what's
needed and to pay them very well
but but the idea that you know the you
know the problem is there's
that's you know it's all turning into
vodka and bourbon and and God knows what
you know who knows what the productivity
of hemp farming will turn into so it's
coming fast apparently not just for go
well one more question on that the crops
that Julian there's so much of crop
yield improvement is affected by genetic
engineering is what is the effect of
that in the long term for Humanity and
for the environment as a whole higher
yields are the result of a set of a
cluster of of innovations a simple one
which is actually extremely important
and part of the way the high yields were
achieved by Randy daddy and David hula
is plant spacing is much closer than it
used to be there were traditional ideas
about how closely you could plant it
also had to do with the way people
worked in fields so there are more
plants per square meter per square yard
then there have been changes and seeds
improved weather forecasts better forms
of aggregate of irrigation fertilizers
of various kinds herbicides pesticides
so there's a range of innovations which
have been used but what the but the the
real growth the real the improvements in
yield as I showed I mean it's just it's
just the data in the last 20 years
yields of potatoes or of corn have kept
going like that
well the inputs of fertilizer and so
forth have been flat or even falling as
a cost or because of environmental
worries well the I think it's more like
I think part of it was an over
enthusiasm when these things were new
and it's also self-medication you know
if you go to the doctor and they give
you they say take some of these pills
antibiotics the doctor says to take you
know whatever one every four hours a lot
of people take two or if you you know
you think two aspirin will get rid of a
headache all the people take four and I
think the a lot of people thought well
this
more fertilizer is good I mean they
fertilizers good I'll put more
fertilizer on and the fertilizer
salesman of course didn't disabuse them
of that notion and I think so there was
a kind of overshoot in the use of inputs
but the the real input that Matt that's
mattering is information it's better
weather forecasts when to do things now
one can consider genetics one form of
information so it's it's a you know it's
it's it's it's one it's another form of
information it's a more precise one crop
breeding has existed for ten thousand
years and as many people say to you from
genetic modification started with
agriculture so people may object to
specific kinds of of genetic
modification now it seems a little
curious to me because you know when you
go to a hospital in San Francisco people
you know we accept now all kinds of
things on ourselves and our children in
the way of genetic modification and
genetic treatments and gene therapy that
we don't want to do to corn so it's
something that seems to me a little
peculiar but but but as with everything
I would always stress you need to
monitor and watch for you know people
can make mistakes things can go wrong
it's impossible to to anticipate every
eventualities
so you know in the in the new forms the
evolving forms of Agriculture it's still
very very important to to put in lots of
sensors and watch things and you know
things can go wrong and do go wrong so
but but I think the but but it's it's
precision we in our work we never use
the word intensification because
intensification gives the incorrect the
untrue image that rising production and
yields in America and other countries
number of other countries in the last 20
years have come from this idea of you
know you're pouring more stuff on on
your acre and that's not what's been
happening in fact in many cases people
have been the applications have been
lower but smarter
you've mentioned climate change just in
passing a couple times once where it
might affect success of agriculture once
where the biosphere seems to be
responding to longer growing seasons and
Marcio to which plants like you were one
of the first half dozen people in
America to look at climate change
seriously
in fact you told me last night that when
you first proposed studying that to I
guess your supervisor at Columbia they
said it's not a subject that's correct
that was 1980 81 91 climate change what
I was told was not a subject it was not
a subject for a doctoral dissertation it
has become a subject for quite a few of
them there's a lot of money there so
you've tracked it in a way more from the
beginning than most people what's your
sort of current thinking and frame and
what do you think about climate change
these days well first I would say in
almost anything can be true about
climate change in the sense that the
black covers a lot well first there's
the question of what emissions will be
in the future now as you can see I
personally think that the economy is
decarbonizing and evolving away at least
at least the American but I think soon
China and India too so I'm I I
personally don't think that the emission
you know the the projections of high
future concentrations I think are as
with a high future use of water I don't
think that's what's going to happen
nevertheless reasonable people can
disagree so some people may think we'll
go to 450 or 500 parts per million and
some people can think we'll go to 900
then in turn there's the question of how
much the carbon dioxide and other
greenhouse gases whatever that go into
the atmosphere how much of those will
stay in the atmosphere how much will be
absorbed by the land how much will go
into the ocean and let's say that can be
between 1/3 and 2/3 so as they're
growing biosphere sucking down more co2
yes it is about in the oceans some of it
is going into the oceans yes a lot of it
is going into the life
there's primary production of algae or
whatever in the oceans are sucking this
stuff down and returning it or is it go
to the bottom of the sea oh no most of
it would sink but the there haven't been
we tried to do some of this in the
census of marine life there have been
there they're just two or three papers
about whether primary productivity in
the oceans that the meadows of the ocean
are growing more the way that the
meadows on land are now growing more and
it's really I would say the evidence
there isn't enough evidence really to
draw strong conclusions yet the plankton
in the oceans of course do you know that
if their photosynthesis if their
chlorophyll based greeting if they're
sort of green plants so to say like
plants on the land they'll use the co2
other plant other animals and plants in
the ocean could grow less but let me
just say I think the the point about
climate change then you have these
different simulation models some of
which are show a lot of climate change
and some of which very little and then
you have the question of what will
happen to agriculture and then will the
societies be like Malawi or Switzerland
so basically you know you can you can
have you know if you think emissions
will be pretty low and the written part
retained in the atmosphere will be
pretty low and the sensitivity is let's
say one and a half degrees not three
then you know if you if you're then you
can have a scenario in which it really
doesn't look like a terribly serious
problem on the other hand if you take
the high end five times then you know
it's the end of the world so so you have
this huge spectrum and so my feeling is
everybody is right it's kind of a
Lockhart you can take your you know it
really depends on how risk-averse and
how you are to begin with I would say in
terms of sort of where you which results
pop out at you well it's an
interestingly and no one knows what's
going to happen that's the basic point
but you have to I mean the question what
the society chooses to do depends again
it's a choice of how risk-averse we are
something terrible could happen uh-huh
and there for some people when you say
you know some people have a lot of
insurance on their lives or their homes
some people wear bicycle helmets some
don't some use seat belts some don't so
so that you know the at the in the end
it's real
for all the science that goes on the
real question is how risk-averse
societies are and so how you know do you
want to spend 1% or 3% or 5% of your
wealth or income because something
terrible could happen okay Kevin Kelly
yes I think probably a question it's
occurring the many here why are common
perceptions so out of whack because the
facts that you present here tonight well
you know I showed early that chart of
the world up to 1970 in 1990 and then
2010 and I I think the view of
destruction of of earth that many people
had in 1970 in fact reflected a lot of
what had gone on in the century up until
then and that created a kind of view
which is which spread and is repeated
and widely held and I think a lot of
people just haven't continued to look at
the actual data so you know it when you
actually look you know then you see that
whether it's America or Europe or the
world then you see that a lot of things
that were projected to go like this have
gone like this and even like this and I
but I think people are sort of still
stuck living on the tangent of 1970 or
1980 well there's an argument that that
kind of dread or fear or panic curve or
deep concern that God sort of instilled
in the 70s is productive and good
because that brings money and attention
in science and saves the whales and why
would we encourage people to relax
I wouldn't say you know I think one has
to you know uh you know I'm not
encouraging people to eat tuna so III
wouldn't I wouldn't it's you know III
think it's first I think it's important
also to share that some of the things
we've done whether it's Kindles and
readers or laws banning use of asbestos
and arsenic that some of these things
have worked so to me that's that's that
doesn't discourage future action that
makes people feel that the the the
things they've done either as
manufacturers or as as households and
consumers or through public life that
that they've had some effect so you know
I if if everything we had done for the
last fifty years you know had not bent
the curves at all that would be to me
that would be cause for such fatalism
then I'd say well then why do anything
because nothing matters so you know I
think the real story is that again that
changes in consumption changes in
production slowing population growth
technical innovation all these things
have made a very big difference and in
many cases favorable so but I would say
as I remarked about Bismarck I think I
think we or let me change the metaphor
mmm you know if that's people were
interested in psychiatry you know
there's always there's the problem of
transference where instead of sort of
trying to deal with the actual problem
you just become engaged in your
relationship with the psychiatrist and
and III haven't spent I think spent a
decade in Washington I feel like there's
this big problem in America in many
other countries where we transfer to
politicians in the political system our
hopes there's a great book called on
power written in occupied France
actually during World World War two by
Baron to juvenile and in it he says
politics is the last repository
of hope and I feel a lot of the time
that we we we think well if we just pass
a law or from Erika signs a treaty that
solves the problem and therefore that
that I have no responsibility and I
think that's a very dangerous attitude
and I think too many people in the
so-called democracies have just sort of
transferred and like psychiatrists they
I think public policy most of the time
doesn't really work so so so you have to
be you need a mix again you need so you
need ereader you need all these that you
need it's part of the mix but you this
idea that you know again legislators or
right you just sign this thing and it
solves the problem it doesn't set it's
part of a much more complex system and
you know what the good things that I've
described are the outcome of of a
variety of actions of companies and
producers realizing they'd make more
money if they made more efficient use of
the resource and the famous armored meat
packing we package everything but the
squeal so so you know if if you know if
you don't throw away a lot of you know
of stuff you know if you use all the
textile or the metal or whatever so so
you know producers can do things that
are more efficient consumers can change
their behaviors governments and public
policy can do things too but but I think
one has to be you know so I think I
don't think it's fatalism at all I think
it's trying to make the various actors
in the society all take some
responsibility I'm trying to you know
the lifelong conservationist and sort of
as part of environmental movement
getting started the current one in the
70s and I think what throws a lot of us
when you say this stuff is that we
didn't do that now we didn't level off
population that was done by urbanization
and by you know people going for
Prosperity and better jobs and all those
kind of stuff
we saved the whales too
Wow but you know Steve Jobs and Jeff
Bezos both whom I know probably would
have been glad to hear that their
inventions would mean fewer trees being
cut down but they would also say that
has nothing to do with why people buy
these products I'm designing and so it's
this inadvertent greening going on that
we're not sure what to do with our heads
in relation to you know a lot of people
dedicated as you've done their lives to
trying to make conservation happen and
environmental responsibility happening
and then you say well actually well it's
just going on anyway and we go well now
what you know we we can't take a bow for
that sometimes the good news alarms us
because we didn't do it we didn't raise
money for it we didn't have this into an
organization that we work with that made
that happen so there's a little bit of
feeling left out I I get a sense that
there is a shift going on of how we
think about humanity's relationship to
nature that is having to embrace the
scope and scale and the speed of what
you've been saying is going on and and
the sense working with it and not
feeling disconcerted by it but you say
wow great don't have to do that one it's
taken care of let's focus on this other
issue here like the oceans that make
sense yes well that you know that's why
I think the you know Bismarck who was a
very successful politician was astute
about how you know you basically you
want to ride the good waves and so you
know I think in most cases that's really
what what successful leadership is about
so so you know some people I'd say well
free will is a sacred cow you know so
it's everybody wants to believe in more
free will than I think really exists you
know if you there are famous studies for
example about merit
and the the marriages and the the the
the probability of the of the person
you'll marry I'm basically marry people
who are near to you and the best
predictor this may be less true now with
aviation and so forth but there were
very thorough studies done and you know
if somebody lives a quarter of a mile
from you or a half a mile from you or a
mile or ten miles you know what there's
a direct perfect relationship between
the probability that you'll marry and so
you know that but everybody likes to
think you know it you know everything is
free but but so I think there's a which
is but you know it's and that you know
it may make us better human beings in
some ways and more risk accepting and
adventurous and entrepreneurial you know
if you really understand the statistics
of business creation you might not
really want to start a business since
our worth
so or a marriage or yeah so so so I
think I have a life baby so you know in
some sense you know getting getting the
sort of right mix of appreciating the
power of the system and still
appreciating what freedom of action we
really have that's a that's very very
important and again I think great
leaders have that or and great
organizations have that it's not it's
not always just a leader so you know the
but you know there are these very
powerful trajectories that extend over
centuries that are not you know are not
the result that are not controlled by
individuals or small groups of people so
if we recognize some of those things
it's you know I you know I sometimes
like to say don't forget the system it
won't forget you so thank you
I hear
[Applause]
[Music]
you